this new information changes the whole
story if you hate somebody why would you
want to meet with them if you want to
meet with why would you invite into your
house
these are questions
and they frame them can be it's a
possibility now because of the new
evidence
that could have been i'm not saying that
did happen that could have been
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and sisters and
dear friends welcome to this video
a few people sent me this
myself today personally just to get some
clarifications on the matter
um a lot of people asked for me to do a
video
on the topic now before i done a video
about it and this was based on
him verbally saying that he did
commit the act now there's a bit of a
change in the story and there's reasons
behind it
now the reason i'm doing this video is
because i'm not a a detective
or anything like that uh or i'm just
trying to jump onto the
scandal or whatever's going on but it's
genuinely to give you guys a reminder a
very important reminder for you guys to
understand when these two kind of things
happen you have to be silent you have to
be very careful
because allegations are very serious and
if you just jump on board without
analyzing the situation
you can make a mistake it's very
important that's why ali
and said that when you hear the story of
someone
wait do not make a judgment emotion
whatever even if they're crying in front
of
until you hear the other side yeah now
in this matter provinces is very simple
new information has arise these this new
information changes the whole story now
because brother dawud kim admit it
and now he's saying that he was forced
to admit
and that he was actually the script that
he was given was given
by them if i'm not mistaken um telling
him word for word what to say
and his family pictures were released
that's what he had to admit
to
about action and also his proto-hidden
admitted this um it was it was a
very silly thing to do because islamic
media you would have get punished
and you would get punished islamic you
would you would get some kind of
punishment
uh in the sharia uh if you live in an
islamic government
of course but then when the truth arises
and these things
do change the whole story a bit because
from what we can see and the screenshots
you can see on the screen bro and
sisters
these individuals these and by the way
i'm not here to say
that happened or it didn't happen and
for you guys
you need to assume the best yes we have
to assume the best in this instance
specifically with what has arisen now
with this new information but i'm not
here to take
sides forward against i just want to
highlight something very important
now in this uh screenshot as you can see
in 15th january 2019
this is the the two sisters i think this
dude called
j kim all his content is absolute is
about muslim people because he's getting
views from them
so he's just capitalizing on it and he
keeps coming into my recommendations
okay this is
this annoying korean youtuber needs to
stop using islam as a way to get views
and subscribers and muslim
caboose got to stop caring about
validation from korean men
okay and the tweet is i can't believe
this gained over 100k
in past two months just because of this
muslim caboose i'm sick and tired of you
all
absolute shambles imagine exploiting
most for youtube views
this is before the accident incident
after incident yeah
if this guy makes one more video about
it someone's going to commit
imagine exploiting most for youtube
clout now
the thing is here these are just a few
tweets here
and this one this problem convert
youtuber jay kim tried to rape my friend
in our apartment after i tried to take
care of him and apartment he was really
drunk
gave him water and food to swab him up
please do not support me he's disgusting
please
read the words they first admitted that
when they first met him
they did not know he was a muslim
youtuber now this is claimed to be false
because of these earlier tweets which
showed that they had
a hate or a grudge towards him now if
someone has some
kind of a hate and grudge against you
that is a biased source
this does not mean just because there
are by a source that what they're saying
may not be true
but what it does tell us is that there
is some kind of an animosity towards
dawood kim
now if there's an animosity what that
would kim does in the sharia
court this will leave a whole
doubt it's a doubt for matano it's like
well hold on a second because they
hate this person it's not like they've
never met and this happened they
hate this person now it gets a bit
more um interesting when they claim they
they met and they didn't give the
address to the house where new
information
shows that the address was clearly given
even in police reports it shows where
the incident happened
and the text message centered though it
came to come to the address was also
there
now what happened allah subhanahu wa
tala knows best in that very house
the wood kim is claiming now that
because he was pressured to make that
testament admitting and all that kind of
stuff he is claiming now that
a water was given to him and in that
water after he drunk he felt dizzy and
he passed out next thing you know he's
been banged in the head or
fallen on the floor now from what he's
saying that when he
that whole incident occurred the
question that needs to be asked is why
did they choose to use that video a year
later
why like why couldn't they you know
get get it out there donna dustin report
him you know to the police i think
he was reported to the police i think
after i don't know i don't know exactly
in details yeah but the question is when
his stuff was missing
he goes to the police station now i
don't even want to put myself in that
situation but
if i was in a situation where i was so
drunk that i tried to
rape somebody the last thing that i
would be thinking about
is my belongings i'll be honest with you
i would not care about
damn about my belongings yeah so the
thing is if
i have been kicked out a house and
they're accusing me of raping someone or
whatever it may be
i'm not going to go to the police
station by the way i was in this house
yeah
and my belongings uh that i've lost my
blood doesn't belong so i'm not gonna do
that i'm just saying i'm not going to be
going to the police station
i will not be going into the vicinity of
any kind of police station
anywhere close so these allegations when
we look at the situation guys it changes
the whole
spectrum of things now
could it be that he was drunk that it
was in the water but he was drunk
and he i don't know tried something with
her i don't know
i don't know if they were both into it
and she changed their mind and said this
is rape i don't know if she
didn't even give her consent from the
beginning and it was the case
oh you know what can it be a possibility
that was this was all set up
they don't like him i'm looking at
possibilities here yeah i'm not
disregarding others
they didn't like him they got uh they
they talked to him they got in contact
with him
they met in a bar they're trying to come
back to the place
they gave him something he passed out or
whatever it may be
they claimed he raped him they took his
stuff out his camera belonging etc
i don't know why they didn't give his
stuff like the camera etc um
and they framed him can be it's a
possibility now because of the new
evidence
that could have been i'm not saying that
did happen that could have been so as
you can see the lines are blurred now
and this is an information and i'll tell
you from first hand experience
as a person in the youtube scene and a
person as a public figure and other
public figures as well
there are sisters out there who do
want to take us down i'll be honest with
you i've done videos about it before
where i would get messages in decent
pictures flirtation
invitation to certain things and 100
surprise protectors not from my own
thing if if it wasn't for allah's
protection uh we are human beings we are
men we are we because weakness is a
woman there's a female i'll tell you
clear cut yeah clerk are we weak towards
a woman yeah
and that's what allah says in the quran
the plot of shaytan is
weak and the plot of a woman is avim not
woman in the
context like her fitnah the way the
weakness that we have towards a woman
so it's by the mercy of allah and i
praise him
that allah protected me and say block
and
you know move away from that you know
allah but protected
yusuf we're not saying we're not
comparing ourselves to you
just saying how allah even says that if
he didn't see our miracles he would have
felt
again say that the point is this guys
there are
genuinely girls and women out there who
want to take us down
genuinely yeah they want to see our
downfall
now with the tweets showing the
animosity towards him
and then they're meeting him casually
like they're okay if you hate somebody
why would you want to meet with him if
you want to meet with why would you
invite into your house
these are questions that need to be
asked once again i'm not saying
that it may have not been the case that
that would kim actually
he can't remember that he attempted this
we don't know
we assume the best assume the best in
the context of the law what we're saying
is
from their perspective i don't know
maybe but there are things that are
big question marks now so what that
means is you cannot take nobody's side
this is a matter where
you just have to say look allah
subhanahu wa tala
no one could talk four against no one
could talk against them no one could
talk
against the wood right now the matter is
like whatever close it
move on that's the best thing to do
brothers and sisters at this moment of
time
he was um forced to make a statement
that he may have not want to and
he didn't look at the information
properly so guys
it's very simple islam says prevention
is better than cure
drinking alcohol getting involved you
know alcohol you know how many house
people in the western world they commit
incest they rape their own siblings
yeah their own children their own
brother sister
incest why because of alcohol the mother
of all evil
alcohol clubbing dog all this kind of
stuff you can see the doors it opens to
rape
even rape this is the reason why islam
is so against rape
so much so that it bans the root to it
that's why allah says
this is why islam has come down to
legislate so these things don't even
occur
cut it from the roots not the branches
go to the roots
so brothers and sisters inshallah this
is a reminder for us to learn and
understand
the dangers and the evil of these things
and i hope this chapter is closed
in this matter in this context since
i've seen the new evidence and stuff
like that i'll be honest guys
the matter has to that like from my
perspective i'll be honest personally if
you ask me
without without being biased i'll be
honest with you like i said
my loyalties with allah's messenger must
mean i i
my loyalty yeah is not without kim
or anyone but to see animosity
beforehand
towards him to me that leaves a big
question mark i'm so sorry if you have
animosity
to someone and all of a sudden you're
meeting him and these things happen it's
like
i don't know but anyways guys hope you
guys enjoyed this video inshallah
and we ask allah subhana wa talk to
protect
be